vor Ort im Bundestag meine Kollegin Ines
Trams aus unserem Hauptstadtstudio
schönen guten Morgen Ines
vorherrschendes Thema beim EU-Gipfel ist
ja der Krieg in der Ukraine mit seinen
Folgen die Rolle Deutschlands in der EU
hat sich etwas verändert mit der neuen
Regierung teilweise bei Olaf Scholz fast
isoliert woran liegt das
ganz genau ich denke Kanzler Scholz wird
heute versuchen nach seinem ersten
regierungsjahr eine positive Bilanz zu
ziehen doch klar ist wenn man schaut auf
sein erstes europapolitisches Jahr dann
steht Berlin dann steht stolz doch
oftmals in Brüssel bei vielen Punkten
isoliert da ein Beispiel nur der Streit
um den gaspreisdeckel während viele
andere EU-Partner diese
gaspreisbremse für importiertes
Flüssigkeit installieren wollen weigert
sich Berlin beharrlich vor allem aus
Sorge dass bei zu niedrigen Gaspreisen
Europa eventuell gar nicht mehr
beliefert werden könnte hinzu kommt dass
mit Blick auf den sogenannten
doppelwumms den das 200 Milliarden Euro
Entlastungspaket ähm Scholz bei vielen
EU-Partnern große Irritationen
hinterlassen hat
da hieß es das würde den Binnenmarkt in
der EU verzerren und Deutschland als
reiches Land würde hier eben ganz allein
seinen eigenen Lösungsweg gehen nicht
bei wenigen Partnern hieß es da
Deutschland wähle eine Germany first
eine Deutschland zuerst Politik
ein großes Problem ist es ja auch dass
die deutsch-französische Achse nicht
mehr so gut funktioniert wie früher
deutsch-französische
Regierungskonsultationen wurden auf das
neue Jahr verschoben ein einmaliger
Vorgang was ist da eigentlich passiert
und was bedeutet das für die EU wenn die
beiden starken Länder nicht mehr wie
gewohnt an einem Strang ziehen
ganz genau der deutsch-französische
Motor stottert zum einen wegen Streits
um die Energiepolitik wie eben schon
angedeutet dieser sogenannte doppelwumms
das 200 Milliarden Euro Rettungspaket
das hat Berlin ohne Rücksprache mit den
EU-Partnern ohne Rücksprache mit Berlin
beschlossen hinzu kommt viel Streit um
die Verteidigungspolitik während
Frankreich gerne auf das
deutsch-französische Projekt fkas in der
Luftverteidigung gesetzt hätte
fokussiert sich Schuld nun auf den
us-tarnkappenbomber F35 von denen er 35
an der Zahl kaufen möchte genauso hat er
eine europäische
raketenabwehrinitiative gestartet ohne
Rücksprache mit Paris das hat dann im
Herbst tatsächlich auch zur Absage der
deutsch-französischen
Regierungskonsultationen geführt
wir schauen mal kurz ins Plenum also
noch hat die Regierungserklärung nicht
begonnen zur Zeit laufen noch
Abstimmungen über
tagesordnungsänderungen daher frage ich
weiter Ines hat diese von Dir
geschilderte schwierige Lage
Deutschlands in der EU auch etwas mit
dem Kommunikationsverhalten des Kanzlers
zu tun woran liegt das eigentlich
ich könnte mir schon vorstellen dass es
auch damit zu tun hat so wie wir Kanzler
Scholz hier auch in Berlin in der
Innenpolitik wahrnehmen so agiert er
eben oftmals auch auf der europäischen
Bühne oftmals ja mit autarken einsam
gefällten Entscheidungen und die kommen
dann eben unabgestimmt bei den
EU-Partnern an ja herzlichen Dank Ines
wir hören der Bundeskanzler wurde
aufgerufen und macht sich jetzt auf dem
Weg zum Pult und beginnt mit der
Regierungserklärung meine Damen und
Herren
wer die Bilder und Berichte wahrnimmt
die uns seit dem 24 Februar Tag für Tag
aus der Ukraine erreichen kann nur zu
einem Ergebnis kommen in diesen Wochen
geht ein besonders schweres Jahr zu Ende
Russlands anders Krieg gegen die Ukraine
ist ein entsetzlicher Einschnitt er
trifft zuallererst die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine sie ertragen seit fast zehn
Monaten Vertreibung und Verschleppung
Verwundung und Tod
aber ein Einschnitt eine Zeitenwende
bedeutet Russlands Kriegs für ganz
Europa und die Welt
die Themen des Europäischen Rates morgen
in Brüssel spiegeln den Ernst der Lage
in die Putin unseren Kontinent gestürzt
wieder
sie belegen aber noch etwas und vor
allem darüber will ich heute sprechen
sie belegen wie fundamental Putin sich
verrechnet hat
Putin glaubte seine Truppen würden die
Ukraine innerhalb von Tagen über Rennen
er glaubte wir in Europa und im
demokratischen Westen sein zu uneinig um
der Ukraine wirksam zu helfen
er glaubte er könne Europas Solidarität
Austrocknen indem er uns den Gashahn
zudreht
aber kein einziger von putinsplänen ist
aufgegangen
weil Putin sich getäuscht hat über den
Mut der ukraineren Ukraine über Europa
über uns über den Charakter unserer
Demokratien über unseren Willen und zu
widersetzen gegen Großmacht waren und
Imperialismus
meine Damen und Herren das ist die
wirkliche Geschichte dieses Jahres 2022
die Ukraine widersteht der russischen
Aggression aber auch wir haben die
Herausforderungen angenommen
gemeinsam mit unseren Freunden und
Partnern haben wir die Ukraine
entschlossen unterstützt finanziell
humanitär und auch mit Waffen diese
Unterstützung setzen wir fort und zwar
genau so lange wie sie benötigt wird
auch deshalb kämpfen die tapferen
Streitkräfte der Ukraine immer
erfolgreicher
und weil das so ist geht Russland dazu
über die ukrainische Infrastruktur zu
zerstören wehrlose Kinder Frauen und
alte mit Raketen zu beschießen
was für eine furchtbare und zugleich
völlig verzweifelte Strategie der
verbrannten Erde
aber auch damit kommt Putin nicht durch
weil die Ukraine und Ukrainer
zusammenstehen und standhalten und weil
wir die Ukraine umso mehr unterstützen
mit allem was sie braucht um auch dieser
niederträchtigen Art der Kriegsführung
zu widerstehen
dazu gehören jetzt Stromgeneratoren und
Transformatoren genauso wie die
Artillerie und Flugabwehrsysteme die wir
liefern
es sind ja nicht zuletzt die
gepard-flaggt Panzer aus Deutschland die
hochwirksam dazu beitragen dass ziemlich
viele russische Flugkörper abgeschossen
werden und gerade jetzt geht es dazu
auch um konkrete Maßnahmen zur
Versorgung der Ukraine mit Wärme Wasser
und Strom
deshalb bin ich unserem französischen
Freunden besonders Emmanuel macron sehr
dankbar für die gestern in Paris
veranstaltete solidaritätskonferenz
dabei ging es gezielt darum wie die
Widerstandskraft der Ukraine in diesem
Winter mit Blick auf die Instandsetzung
der Energieinfrastruktur gestärkt werden
kann
auch im Europäischen Rat werden wir uns
darüber weiter abstimmen
zugleich sorgen wir dafür dass die
Ukraine auch 2023 die finanziellen
Mittel bekommt die sie braucht zusammen
mit den internationalen Partnern hat
Europa der ukrainischen Regierung seit
kriegsberinnen bereits umfangreiche
Finanzhilfen geleistet für 2023 stellt
die EU der Ukraine weitere 18 Milliarden
Euro an außerordentlicher Finanzhilfe
planbar und zielgerecht zur Verfügung
denn die Ukraine muss jetzt in die Lage
versetzt werden diesen Winter zu
überstehen
mit Blick auf die Zukunft will ich hier
aber auch anmerken
wer immer glaubt er könne die Grundwerte
der EU zu denen sich alle
Mitgliedsstaaten verpflichtet haben
ausspielen gegen die Außen- und
sicherheitspolitische Handlungsfähigkeit
der Union der wird damit scheitern
meine Damen und Herren auch die Arbeit
am marschallplan für die Land den
langfristigen wieder auf der Ukraine
kommt voran im Oktober haben wir führen
der Experte und Experten der Welt hier
in Berlin zusammengebracht um dafür
Konzepte zu entwickeln jetzt treiben wir
die Bildung einer internationalen
geberplattform voran die den
Wiederaufbau koordinieren wird erst
vorgestern haben wir uns mit unserem
Partnern in der G7 und mit der EU auf
Eckpfeiler dieser Plattform geeinigt
zugleich werden wir in der G7 weiter
zusammenarbeiten um weltweit die
Schwächsten in der Welt vor den Folgen
dieses krises zu schützen in dem
Russland auch Ernährung und Energie
gezielt als Waffe einsetzt
parallel dazu erhöhen wir den
sanktionsdruck auf Putins Regime
das Embargo der EU für Öl aus Russland
ist ein Kraft seit vorletzter Woche gilt
in Europa in den G7 und darüber hinaus
der vereinbarte ölpreisdecke
die Sanktionen gegen Russland werden wir
so lange aufrechterhalten und weiter
verschärften wie Putin seinen brutalen
Angriffskrieg fortsetzt
meine Damen und Herren der russische
Angriffskrieg bedeutet eine
Herausforderung für den Zusammenhalt der
Europäischen Union
aber auch diese Herausforderung haben
wir angenommen gemeinsam und stark
Europa steht seit dem 24 Februar fest
zusammen dafür hat die Bundesregierung
von Anfang an gearbeitet wir haben
unsere Partner unterstützt und umgekehrt
ihre Unterstützung erfahren das ist
gelebte europäische Solidarität
auch im Hinblick auf die Verteidigung
unserer Freiheit und Sicherheit in
Europa haben wir die vergangenen Monate
intensiv genutzt hier in Deutschland in
Europa und in der NATO haben wir uns
verteidigungspolitisch neu ausgerichtet
unsere Bündnispartner wissen genau sie
können sich auf uns verlassen sie wissen
wir werden falls nötig jeden einzelnen
Quadratmeter des bündnisgebiets
verteidigen
dafür haben wir das Sondervermögen von
100 Milliarden beschlossen die größte
Investition in unsere Bundeswehr seit
ihrem bestehenden wird damit möglich
dafür rüsten wir unsere Streitkräfte
nach Jahren der Vernachlässigung endlich
angemessen aus
dafür geschaffen wir moderne F35
Kampfjets und leisten weiter unseren
deutschen Beitrag zur Teilhabe in der
Allianz
dafür halten wir in diesem Jahr und in
den nächsten beiden Jahren bis zu 17.000
Soldaten für die NATO response fast vor
dafür übernehmen wir 2023 erneut die
Führung der schnellen
nato-eingreiftruppe
dafür werden wir ab 2025 für die
NATO-Streitkräfte Struktur dauerhaft
30.000 Soldaten bereitstellen
dafür sind wir mit Kräften des Heeres
und der lufthafe in der slowakei-präsent
dafür sichern wir mit unserer Luftwaffe
und den Luftraum über Estland oder
erhöhen die Präsenz unserer Marine in
der Ostsee
dafür haben wir den nato-gefechtsverband
in Litauen dauerhaft verstärkt und
verbessern so die Verteidigung des
ganzen Baltikums
dafür verstärken wir gemeinsam mit
Norwegen und anderen Küstenstaaten aus
NATO EU den Schutz von Pipelines und
anderer kryptischer offshore
Infrastruktur
und dafür habe ich vor drei Monaten in
Prag auch den Vorschlag gemacht ein
raketenschutzschirm aufzubauen um so die
europäischen Fähigkeiten innerhalb der
NATO zu stärken
es ist gut dass sich schon 15 Partner
unsere Initiative angeschlossen haben
und es ist gut dass wir in der EU
beschlossen haben unsere Partner
weltweit allen voran die Ukraine mit
neuen Mitteln der europäischen
friedensfazilität weiter zu unterstützen
mit allen diesen Maßnahmen stärken wir
nicht nur die Sicherheit unserer Freunde
und Alliierten sind zugleich auch unsere
eigene Sicherheit
mit allen diesen Maßnahmen stärken wir
das Vertrauen aller Partner in unsere
Bereitschaft im Bündnis Verantwortung zu
übernehmen diesen Kurs haben wir seit
dem 24 Februar entschlossen
eingeschlagen diesen Kurs halten wir
meine Damen und Herren Europas
Sicherheit das bedeutet auch Europas
Energiesicherheit
auf keinem anderen Gebiet haben wir in
so kurzer Zeit so großen Fortschritt
erzielt
nichts beweist das so deutlich wie die
Eröffnung des ersten schwimmenden
Terminals für Flüssiggas den wir am
Sonnabend in Wilhelmshaven feiern werden
im Juli war Baubeginn und jetzt ist
dieses erste deutsche lng-
schon diese Woche wird das erste Schiff
mit Flüssiggas in Wilhelmshaven anlegen
seit Monaten habe ich das angekündigt
und seit Monaten haben mich Leute
unglaublich angeguckt und gesagt noch in
diesem Jahr das wird doch nie was
das hat vermutlich auch Wladimir Putin
gedacht
aber das
ist was geworden und die nächsten
Terminals folgen in Kürze in lubminen im
Brunsbüttel und den Stade
ich glaube ich spreche im Namen von
allen oder fast allen in diesem Haus
wenn ich sage
herzlichen Dank an alle Arbeiterinnen
Arbeiter an alle Ingenieure und
Ingenieure die im Rekordtempo diese
großartige Leistung vollbracht haben
auch ihnen verdanken wir dass wir in
diesem Jahr gut durch den Winter kommen
so sie stehen für viele Millionen
Bürgern und Bürger in unserem Land die
in dieser schwierigen Zeit einfach
anpacken die mit ihrem Zusammenhalt und
mit ihrer guten Arbeit dafür sorgen dass
wir über die Runden kommen
auf jede und jeden von ihnen kommt es an
mit unseren entlastungspaketen und dem
200 Milliarden Abwehrschirm gegen die
Folgen des russischen Angriffskrieg tut
die Bundesregierung alles nur Mögliche
um die Lage der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und der Unternehmen zu erleichtern so
und nur so kommen wir gemeinsam durch
diese Zeit
meine Damen und Herren gemeinsam das
bedeutet vor allem gemeinsam in Europa
nie zuvor haben wir ein Energiefragen so
eng zusammengearbeitet wir haben uns
auch gemeinsame Energiesparziele
geeinigt und wir haben uns darauf
verständigt dass wir die hohen
Strompreise abfedern
wir arbeiten am gemeinsamen Einkauf von
Gas so dass wir auch nächstes Jahr
unsere Speicher gut füllen können
dabei ist klar einfacher Sofortlösung
gibt es nicht zum Beispiel können wir
nicht so in Preise Eingreifen dass dann
zu wenig Gas nach Europa geliefert wird
diese Einsicht ist auch für die
Verständigung wichtig an der der
energierat der EU gestern
weitergearbeitet hat und ich bin sicher
wir werden eine gute pragmatische
Verständigung erzielen
meine Damen und Herren in einer weiteren
Hinsicht erweist sich putinskrieg als
Beschleuniger notwendiger Veränderung
für den Umstieg auf erneuerbare Energie
steht diese Bundesregierung von Anfang
an aber jetzt ist klar die Erneuerbaren
brauchen wir nicht nur wegen der
Klimakrise wir brauchen sie auch zu
unserer Sicherheit damit wir nie wieder
zu abhängig sind von einzelnen
Lieferanten aus beiden Gründen arbeiten
wir daran dass Europa zum ersten
klimanotalen Kontinent wird und auch
dabei kommen wir schnell voran
viele Elemente des Pakets fit vor 505
der EU werden gegenwärtig noch
verhandelt wir setzen uns dabei ein für
ehrgeizige Ziele für den mutigen
Einstieg in die nächste große Epoche
unser europäischen Industriegeschichte
in der wir mit klimaneutraler
technologiesichere neue Arbeit und neuen
Wohlstand schaffen
meine Damen und Herren
auch in den Prozess der eu-erweitung hat
putinskrieg neuen Schwung gebracht
die Ukraine der Ukraine Moldau und
perspektivisch Georgien haben wir im
Juni den Weg zur EU-Mitgliedschaft
eröffnet
aber wir haben endlich auch wieder den
Beitrittsprozess der sechs Staaten des
westlichen Balkan unter dampfgesetzt das
ist mir ein besonderes Anliegen
das Gipfeltreffen des berlin-prozesses
am 3 november im Kanzleramt hat gezeigt
Konflikte der Vergangenheit sind wie wir
wieder spüren nicht vorüber aber
überwindbar
Fortschritt Richtung EU-Mitgliedschaft
ist möglich
diese Einschätzung habe ich letzte Woche
beim eu-westbal kein Gipfel in Tirana
ausdrücklich bekräftigt
dafür setze ich mich auch weiter in
energisch ein morgen beim Europäischen
Rat und auch im kommenden Jahr
da muss es richtig das sind dieser Woche
auch Bosnien-Herzegowina zum
EU-Beitrittskandidaten wird es liegt in
unserem deutschen und in unserem
europäischen Interesse dass der
restliche balkanteil der Europäischen
Union wird
genauso liegt es in unserem Interesse
das Kroatien ab 23 zum Schengen Raum
gehören wird und es liegt in unserem
Interesse das Rumänien und Bulgarien
bald folgen
[Applaus]
das ist noch nicht gemacht aber wir
müssen auf diesem Weg weiter vorankommen
meine Damen und Herren Putins Krieg hat
auch bei vielen Fragen nach der Zukunft
der Globalisierung und nach Europas
Rolle in der Welt des 21 jahrhunderts
neue Klarheit geschaffen heute Mittag
reise ich ja zuerst zum eu-asiengipfel
in Brüssel
das wird das erste Gipfeltreffen
überhaupt dass die Regierungschefs der
EU und des asiatischen staatenverbandes
so zusammenbringt gemeinsam haben die 10
Asien Staaten 670 Millionen Einwohner
wir in der EU sind 450
schon diesem normzahlen zeigen die
Vorstellung einer bipolaren Ehre in der
sich alles um die USA und China dreht
geht an der globalen Wirklichkeit vorbei
natürlich an der herausgehobenen Rolle
der USA besteht kein Zweifel auch nicht
an der Rivalität zwischen den USA und
China
mit unserem wichtigsten globalen Partner
den USA verbinden uns Europäer dabei
vielfältige gemeinsame Werte und
Interessen
gerade dieses Jahr entweder gezeigt wie
unverzichtbar das transatlantische
Bündnis ist
das schließt Differenzen in Einzelfragen
nicht aus die amerikanischen
Investitionen in den Klimaschutz sind
ein beeindruckender Beitrag zur
Transformation der US-Wirtschaft und
auch das muss an dieser Stelle und hier
gesagt werden lange haben wir uns
gewünscht dass eine solche Zielrichtung
in den USA verfolgt wird
aber sie dürfen auch das ist klar nicht
den fairen Wettbewerb verhindern darum
unterstütze ich sehr dass die
Europäische Kommission intensive
Gespräche mit den USA führt ich habe mit
dem amerikanischen Präsidenten
gesprochen der französischen Präsident
hat das auch getan denn wir dürfen uns
im transatlantischen Verhältnis nicht
auseinander dividieren lassen im
Gegenteil statt einer großen
Auseinandersetzung sollten wir noch
enger zusammenarbeiten und den
gemeinsamen und fairen Handel mit den
USA stärken
meine Damen und Herren Chinas Aufstieg
zur Weltmacht ist eine Tatsache mit der
wir
zurechtkommen müssen
dabei wäre es falsch zu recht kommen mit
abkoppeln zu übersetzen mit die kappling
oder die Globalisierung das wäre nicht
der richtige Weg als Wirtschafts- und
Handelspartner bleibt China für uns
wichtig
und über viele globale fragen wollen und
müssen wir mit China sprechen auch da wo
wir eben unterschiedlich auf
Sachverhalte blicken
bei meinem Besuch in China habe ich klar
zum Ausdruck gebracht dass Deutschland
Europa für eine regelbasierte
internationale Ordnung einstehen fest
verankert in der Kater der Vereinten
Nationen
unsere Sorgen über die wachsende
Unsicherheit im Südchinesischen Meer und
in der Straße von Taiwan habe ich sehr
deutlich formuliert das war wichtig
aber wichtig war zugleich das Präsident
sie und ich in einer entscheidenden
Frage einig war
einig darüber dass bereits die Drohung
mit dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen und
zulässig ist einig darüber dass der
Einsatz von Atomwaffen eine rote Linie
überschreiten würde die die Menschheit
zu Recht gezogen hat
ich hoffe sehr dass diese klare und
gemeinsame Botschaft auch in Moskau
angekommen ist mit seinem gewalttätigen
Großmacht waren steht Russland heute so
alleine da wie nie zuvor auf dem G20
Gipfel kürzlich auf Party war das für
alle Welt zu sehen
meine Damen und Herren
die Welt ist 21 jahrhunderts wird eine
multipolare Welt sein wenn es um Lösung
für die großen globalen Themen geht
Klimaschutz Pandemien Biodiversität oder
Digitalisierung dann müssen wir unsere
Netze weiter auswerfen
dann müssen wir nicht nur unsere
lieberketten diversifizieren sondern
auch unsere Verhandlung und Verbindungen
alle Teile der Welt dann brauchen wir
enge und vertrauensvolle Partnerschaften
besonders mit den aufstrebenden Nationen
in Asien in Afrika in Landratten in
Amerika und in der Karibik
darum haben wir zum diesjährigen
g7-gipfel in Emma auch die
Regierungschefs wichtiger demokratischer
Staaten des globalen Südens eingeladen
darum bin ich in diesem Jahr gezielt in
Länder wie Vietnam und Singapur Japan
und Indonesien Südafrika Senegal oder
Niger gereist
darum habe ich Premierminister Modi zu
deutschindischen
Regierungskonsultationen empfangen
und darum haben wir unsere gesamte
deutsche G7 Präsidentschaft genutzt um
für die Gründung eines offenen
kooperativen
internationalen klimaklubs zu werben um
so den globalen Klimaschutz
voranzubringen
es ist ein erfreulicher Abschluss
unserer Präsidentschaft dass die G7
Anfang dieser Woche den Rahmen dieses
Clubs förmlich beschlossen hat
wir werden jetzt schnell auf weitere
Staaten zugehen damit der klimaklub zu
vereinten Anstrengungen gegen den
Klimawandel führt
meine Damen und Herren
niemand leidet so sehr unter Russlands
Angriffskrieg wie die Ukraine und
Ukraine wir stehen fest an ihrer Seite
aber auch uns Deutsche umso Freunde und
Partner hat putinskrieg vor enorme
Herausforderungen gestellt
diese Herausforderung und Aufgaben haben
wir angenommen an diesen
Herausforderungen sind wir gemeinsam
gewachsen
und diejenigen die nicht geglaubt haben
dass wir das können die haben sich
gewaltig geirrt
das ist die gute Nachricht die am Ende
dieses so bitteren Jahres zuversichtlich
stimmt wir in Deutschland haben
gemeinsam den richtigen Weg
eingeschlagen wir stehen zusammen wir
lassen niemanden allein
das war die sehr außenpolitisch geprägte
Regierungserklärung des Kanzlers Scholz
verurteilte Putin für seine
niederträchtige Art der Kriegsführung
versprach weitere Hilfen für die Ukraine
nicht nur Waffen wer meine er könnte die
eu-spalten der Irre sich betonte Scholz
gleichzeitig lobte er natürlich die
Ampel mit ihren entlastungspaketen mit
dem schnellen Aufbau von
lng-terminals und mit dem 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen
nächster Redner ist nun
Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz
ich eröffne nun die Aussprache und
zuerst hat das Wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion Friedrich Merz
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wir begrüßen
ausdrücklich dass Sie Herr Bundeskanzler
vor dem letzten Europäischen Rat in
diesem Jahr und auch vor dem ersten
eu-asien Gipfel heute eine
Regierungserklärung vor dem Deutschen
Bundestag abgeben wir teilen ihre
Einschätzung des russischen
Angriffskrieges gegen die Ukraine und
vor allem ihre Bewertung der Entwicklung
dieses Krieges in den letzten Wochen das
russische Regime unter Präsident Putin
verübt mit den gezielten Angriffen gegen
die Infrastruktur des Landes gegen die
Wohnbezirke gegen Kinderheime gegen
Krankenhäuser und Altenheime schwerste
Kriegsverbrechen für die Putin und seine
Stärken eines Tages von der
Weltgemeinschaft zur Rechenschaft
gezogen
wir stimmen ihnen zu Herr Bundeskanzler
dass die Europäische Union und die NATO
in den Wochen und Monaten seit dem
Beginn dieses Krieges am 24 Februar
zusammengewachsen sind und sich als
handlungsfähig erwiesen haben
Putin und seinen verbrecherisches Regime
haben vor allem die
Widerstandsfähigkeit der Ukraine die
Standhaftigkeit ihrer Regierung unter
Präsident selensky die Opferbereitschaft
und die Leidensfähigkeit ihrer
Bevölkerung und auch die
Einsatzfähigkeit und Kampfkraft der
Armee vollkommen unterschätzt
wir können uns zum Ende dieses wie sie
es gesagt haben besonders schweren
Jahres Herr Bundeskanzler wir können zum
Ende dieses Jahres dem ukrainischen Volk
nur mit größtem Respekt unsere
Anerkennung und auch unsere Anteilnahme
an ihrem Schicksal aussprechen
zum Ende
zum Ende des Jahres trauern die Familien
in der Ukraine um viele tausend
Gefallene und verwundete Soldaten um
viele tausend getötete Kinder junge und
ältere Menschen unschuldige Männer und
Frauen die diesen Kriegsverbrechen zum
Opfer gefallen sind und wenn wir meine
Damen und Herren in wenigen Tagen unser
Weihnachtsfest feiern dann sind in
unserem Land in dem wir doch das große
Glück haben in Frieden und Freiheit zu
leben dann sind unsere Gedanken auch bei
den Menschen in der Ukraine die
unvorstellbares Leid und unvorstellbare
not in diesen Tagen aushalten müssen
dem Winter
dem Land steht im Winter
dem Land steht im Winter weiterhin
schwere Wochen und Monate bevor es ist
deshalb wichtig dass wir unsere
Unterstützung und Hilfsbereitschaft auch
erneut unterstreichen und darin nicht
nachlassen das gilt für die humanitäre
und finanzielle Hilfe das gilt aber auch
für die militärische Hilfe und anders
als der eine oder andere in diesem Haus
und außerhalb mein sagen und denken zu
müssen verlängert unsere Hilfe diesen
Krieg nicht das Gegenteil ist richtig je
mehr wir helfen je mehr wir helfen umso
schneller ist dieser Krieg vorüber und
deshalb Herr Bundeskanzler bleiben wir
dabei ja Deutschland hat nach langem
Zögern einiges an wichtigem
militärischen Gerät geliefert aber nach
wie vor fehlen der ukrainischen Armee
Schützenpanzer und Kampfpanzer die wir
aus unseren Beständen und aus Beständen
der Industrie liefern können
auch fast zehn Monate nach Beginn dieses
Krieges verstehen sie sich Herr
Bundeskanzler verstecken sie sich immer
noch hinter den NATO-Partnern die
angeblich auch nicht liefern wollen wir
wissen mittlerweile dass dies falsch ist
es liegt vor allem an Ihnen ganz
persönlich dass die Ukraine diese Hilfe
nicht bekommt
sie haben in ihrer Rede gesagt wir haben
in Deutschland hier unsere
Verteidigungspolitik neu ausgerichtet
Herr Bundeskanzler das
bemerken die Nato-Partner und die
Europäische Union anders sie bleiben
weit hinter den Zusagen zurück die sie
von dieser Stelle aus am 27 februar in
ihrer Regierungserklärung gegeben haben
der Verteidigungsetat der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland singt und wenn wir viel
Glück haben dann wird heute im Laufe des
Tages der erste Beschluss des
Haushaltsausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages getroffen aus diesen 100
Milliarden Euro nun die ersten Mittel
freizugeben zehn Monate nach dem Beginn
des Krieges mehr als ein halbes Jahr
nachdem wir hier unter großen Zeitdruck
der von ihnen gesetzt worden ist die
Änderung des Grundgesetzes beschlossen
haben diese Einschätzung die sie hier
abgegeben haben stimmt nicht mit der
Wirklichkeit
sie haben in ihrer Regierungserklärung
Herr Bundeskanzler die richtige
Zusammenarbeit innerhalb der
Europäischen Union angesprochen und
natürlich wir teilen diese Einschätzung
auch in dieser Frage mit ihnen aber so
wortreich und gut funktionieren sie
diese Zusammenarbeit dargestellt haben
es ist doch nicht zu übersehen dass wir
zurzeit eine tiefe Störung des
deutsch-französischen Verhältnisses
erleben sehr viele Beobachter in Berlin
und vor allem in Paris sprechen von
einem Tiefpunkt der Beziehungen und es
war der französische Staatspräsident der
Ihnen am Rande des letzten Gipfels in
Brüssel gesagt hat wörtlich es ist nicht
gut wenn sich Deutschland isoliert und
der
tagesspiegelt heute
Einzelgänger in der EU-Politik Herr
Bundeskanzler das ist die Wahrnehmung
anderer außerhalb ihrer Regierung und
ich füge eine Bemerkung hinzu
da sie noch einmal Bezug genommen haben
auf ihre Rede die sie im August im
Sommer in Prag an der Karlsuniversität
gehalten haben sie haben in dieser Rede
Frankreich die deutsch-französischen
Beziehungen die gemeinsame
Gründungsgeschichte in der Europäischen
Union und die deutsch-französische
Freundschaft als einem der wichtigsten
Pfeiler der EU-Politik mit keinem
einzigen Wort erwähnt das mag vielleicht
in ihrer Regierung niemand bemerkt haben
aber in Paris ist das mit größter
Aufmerksamkeit wahrgenommen worden und
das ist die Realität ihrer Europa
meine Damen und Herren
wir haben heute eine ganze Liste von
Themen gehört von ihnen die sie genannt
haben was jetzt in den nächsten Tagen
weiter zu geschehen hat ich finde es
einmal so sagen sie Listen wie ein guter
Anwalt
akribisch das Inventar auf dass ich in
dem Haus befindet dass wir gemeinsam
bewohnen aber ihnen fehlt fast völlig
der Blick für die Statik dieses Hauses
für das Fundament dieses Hauses und
Ihnen fehlt die Fantasie eines
Architekten und der entschlossene Wille
eines Baumeisters dieses Haus in Europa
jetzt wetterfest und zukunftsfähig zu
machen und vielleicht in diesem Haus in
Europa sogar einen neuen Teil zu bauen
und wenn sie jetzt so dazwischen rufen
dann will ich Ihnen drei konkrete
Beispiele nennen über die wir heute
morgen eigentlich auch sprechen müssten
sie haben über die
deutsch-amerikanischen die europäische
amerikanischen Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
gesprochen was folgt denn aus dieser
Beschreibung die sie heute morgen
abgegeben haben
dass das im Klartext dass sie und sie
die SPD und die Grünen jetzt dafür sind
das mit Amerika ein neues
Freihandelsabkommen ausverhandelt wird
ja oder nein meine Damen und Herren sie
haben hier über China gesprochen und
über die Notwendigkeit uns etwas
unabhängiger zu machen von China sie
treffen sich richtigerweise mit den
aseanstaaten jetzt in Brüssel was heißt
das denn konkret etwa im Hinblick auf
die Handelsbeziehungen zu Südamerika
sind sie jetzt dafür dass das Merkur
surabkommen das ausverhandelt ist mit
den südamerikanischen Staaten sind Sie
dafür dass das ratifiziert und
verabschiedet wird als ein neues
Freihandels kommen zwischen der
Europäischen Union und der Märkte mehr
Kultur starten
und dann muss ich Ihnen sagen der
Bundeskanzler das hat mich nun wirklich
fast
entsetzt sie geben in ihrer
Regierungserklärung ich bin gespannt ob
sie gleich immer noch so reagieren ist
Ihnen eigentlich aufgefallen dass der
Bundeskanzler in seiner
Regierungserklärung nicht ein einziges
Wort zu den Vorgängen im Iran gesagt hat
meine Damen und Herren in diesem Land
werden seit
drei Monate auf offener Straße
Demonstranten erschossen dieses Land
versorgt die Hisbollah und die Hamas mit
den finanziellen Mitteln die diesen
Terror überhaupt erst möglich machen
dieses Land finanziert die Drohnen die
Russland einsetzt gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung in der Ukraine und sie
erwähnen dieses Land mit keinem einzigen
Wort Herr Bundeskanzler es wäre doch
richtig gewesen am heutigen Morgen zu
sagen dass sie sich dafür einsetzen dass
dieses Land jetzt vollkommen isoliert
wird und das von Deutschland aus eine
Initiative ausgeht die dieses Land Iran
jetzt so zu isolieren dass es keine
Chance mehr hat diesen internationalen
Terrorismus zu finanzieren warum
warum geben sie uns in der Befragung
ihrer Regierung
keine Antwort auf die Frage ob sie sich
bei diesem Gipfel der jetzt in Brüssel
stattfindet dafür einsetzen diese
sogenannten revolutionsgarten die die
Stütze des Regimes sind als eine
Terrororganisation einzustufen warum
bekommen wir noch nicht einmal
eine Regierung wenn wir Ihnen diese
Frage stellen ja oder nein Herr
Bundeskanzler
ihre
Regierungserklärung enthält viel
Richtiges keine Frage mit dem wir
einverstanden sind und was wir
selbstverständlich aus Überzeugung auch
Mitverantwortlichen wollen aber es fällt
doch auf das ganz wesentliche Teile
fehlen und dass sie vor allem den Fragen
gezielt aus dem Wege gehen die in ihrer
Regierung offenkundig streitig sind auf
die das stärkste und
bevölkerungsreichste Land der
Europäischen Union aber eigentlich
gerade zum Abschluss des Jahres 2022
eine Antwort geben müsste Herr
Bundeskanzler diese Antworten bleiben
sie und Schuld
das war Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz
der sehr nachdenklich und moderat anfing
auch die Regierung mal lobte aber dann
folgte heftige Kritik so bemängelte er
zum Beispiel dass Deutschland zu wenig
schwere waffenlieferer an die Union an
die Ukraine auf die Mittel aus dem
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr würden
zu spät freigegeben ein schwerer Fehler
sei das Schlechte schwierige
deutsch-französische Verhältnis und das
Scholz die Lage in Iran mit keinem Wort
erwähnt habe sei das falsche Signal so
märz ist folgt nun Katharina dröge
kofraktionsvorsitzende von Bündnis 90
grüne für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Katharina dröge
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja gerade in
diesen Tagen zeigt sich wie wichtig die
Europäische Union ist dass wir die EU
dringlicher denn je brauchen und sie
vermehrt sie haben ja gerade große Worte
darüber gefunden dass wir an einem
Europa der Zukunft bauen müssen aber
wenn man zurückschaut auf die Politik
der CDU und CSU in den letzten Jahren in
Europa dann war es gerade der Kurs von
Wolfgang Schäuble der Europa so
gespalten hat der besserwisserische
belehrende Ton den Wolfgang Schäuble dem
die Union gegenüber insbesondere die
Ländern Süd Europas hatten dieser elende
Kurs der aus der realitätspolitik mit
dem Sie viele Süd europäische Länder zur
Privatisierung gezwungen haben wichtige
Investitionen verhindert haben das ist
ihr Erbe und das hat Deutschland ruft
bei unseren europäischen Nachbarländern
schwer belastet dass ihr Erde in Europa
Politik
ja wir arbeiten an einer Europa der
Zukunft und das ist wirklich harte
Arbeit 27 Mitgliedstaaten mit vielen
unterschiedlichen Perspektiven die jeden
Tag miteinander um den besten Weg Ringen
aber auch zeigen dass wir handeln können
wir haben hart gerungen um harte
Sanktionen gegen den Iran ein Regime das
erfurchtbare Weise Terror ausübt gegen
seine eigene Bevölkerung das junge
Menschen einsperrt foltert und
hinrichtet nur weil sie es wagen eine
eigene Meinung zu haben nur weil sie es
wagen von einem Leben in Freiheit zu
träumen das auszuhalten das ist extrem
schwer und wir arbeiten jeden Tag daran
dafür zu sorgen dass die Welt hinschaut
wir arbeiten jeden Tag daran ist diesem
Regime schwerer zu machen und
insbesondere die deutsche
Außenministerin war ist doch sie dafür
gesorgt hat dass am Montag weitere
Sanktionen in der Europäischen Union
beschlossen werden ganz persönlich
herzlichen Dank Annalena dafür ist weiß
wie hart das ist was du da gerade
leistest
aber sie haben erst wenn sie das hier zu
Recht ansprechen mit dem Iran dann muss
ich Ihnen sagen ich werde Ihnen
persönlich nicht vergessen dass sie hier
im Plenum gelacht haben als die deutsche
Außenministerin über feministische
Außenpolitik gesprochen hat sie haben
sich zurückgelehnt breitbeinig und haben
das Thema nichts ernst genommen als wir
das auf die Tagesordnung gesetzt haben
fangen sie erstmal mit ihrer eigenen
Wertehaltung an bevor sie hier andere
kritisieren ja wir reden in Europa um
die besten Antworten das heißt auch zum
Beispiel im Umgang mit Orban es war
schäbig das Orban ausgerechnet die
Hilfen für die Ukraine genutzt hat um
die Europäische Union zu erpressen gut
dass ich eine Mehrheit der
Mitgliedstaaten nicht davon hat
beeindrucken lassen ja es hätte noch
mehr sein müssen aber das der
rechtsstaatlichkeitsmechanismus ist
angewendet wird das ist ein historisches
Signal und zeigt wozu die Europäische
Union in diesen Zeiten fähig ist und
wozu europäische unionfähig ist das hat
sie insbesondere gezeigt angesichts des
furchtbaren angriffskriegs in Russland
gegen die Ukraine geführt hat wir haben
zusammengestanden wir haben schnelle und
harte sanktionspakete auf den Weg
gebracht und gerade jetzt in diesem
Winter der lang dunkel und kalt wird für
die Menschen in der Ukraine ist es so
wichtig dass wir weiterhin mehr helfen
beim Thema zivile Infrastruktur mit
Hilfsgütern mit Generationen mit
Heizgeräten mit Containern all das was
wir liefern können um den Menschen in
der Ukraine jetzt durch diese Zeit zu
helfen müssen wir tun und das heißt auch
Unterstützung mit Waffen heißt auch
Unterstützung mit mehr Waffen das ist
wichtig in dieser Zeit
aber Herr Merz wenn Sie hier diese Worte
über die Ukraine finden und die waren
angemessen und empathisch am Anfang dann
sage ich Ihnen auch Solidarität mit der
Ukraine zeigt sich auch im Umgang mit
geflüchteten mit den Menschen die hier
hinkommen die unsere Hilfe brauchen und
dass die Union in dieser Zeit in der so
viele Menschen auf unsere Unterstützung
angewiesen sind immer wieder Kampagnen
gegen geflüchtete fährt immer wieder
schärficks wie die CSU in dieser Woche
gegen geflüchtete Macht über
sozialtourismus spricht über Politik
spricht das ist unsolidarisch auch
gegenüber den Menschen aus der Ukraine
das macht das Leben von diesen Menschen
hier schwieriger und das ist ihre
Verantwortung die
ja und wir brauchen die EU auch um
Antworten zu geben auf die großen
geopolitischen Herausforderungen dieser
Zeit im Umgang mit China und auch im
Umgang mit den USA das was die USA mit
dem Inflation reduction Act machen das
ist eine krasse Ansage auf der einen
Seite zeigen sie wie ernst man machen
kann beim Klimaschutz und auf der
anderen Seite ist es eine
Herausforderung für uns weil diese
Politik im Kern protektionistisch ist
darauf müssen wir in der Europäischen
Union eine Antwort geben unser Ziel ist
hierbei klar wir müssen Europa zum
Leitmarkt machen für
Zukunftstechnologien zum Leitmarkt
machen für grüne Technologien das zu
fördern ist die beste Antwort die wir
auf den Inflation redakt geben können
dazu gehört übrigens auch auch unserer
Industrie hier vor Ort zu helfen fit zu
werden für den klimaneutralen Markt der
Zukunft und Herr Merz dieser Reflex
immer alles zu kritisieren was die
Regierung macht und immer alles doof zu
finden nur weil es von der Regierung
kommt die hat genau an dieser Stelle
nicht funktioniert als sie Herr Herberg
dafür kritisiert haben dass wir jetzt
Verträge mit der Industrie auflegen
damit sie umstellen können auf grünen
Wasserstoff damit sie umstellen können
auf eine klimaneutrale Stahlproduktion
da haben sie das kritisiert haben das
schlecht gefunden und haben sogar
vergessen dass es in ihrem eigenen
Bundestagswahlprogramm statt dieser
Reflex einfach nur alles durchzufinden
der ist im Kern populistisch der ist im
Kern nicht ernsthaft und ich wundere
mich wirklich ich habe in den letzten
Wochen mehr schärficks von der Union
gefunden zu irgendwelchen Leuten die
sich auf Straßen festkleben als eine
Zukunft gerichtete Antwort für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland sie
hatten mal vor eine Wirtschaftspartei zu
sein im Kern haben sie keine Antworten
auf die Zukunft unseres Landes will aber
der klimaneutralen Wirtschaft noch beim
Thema fachkräftestrategie wo sie auch
einfach gegen alles sind was der
Wirtschaft helfen würde den
Fachkräftemangel in diesem Land zu
bekämpfen das ist keine ernsthafte
Oppositionspolitik die CDU hatte mal den
Anspruch eine staatstragende Partei zu
sein momentan haben sie sich in eine
Populismus Opposition
zurückgezogen ich hoffe sie kriegen das
in Zukunft wieder besser hin
die Fraktionsvorsitzende der Grünen
macht die Vorgängerregierung für das
Bild Deutschlands in der EU
verantwortlich vor allem den damaligen
Finanzminister Schäuble in der
Finanzkrise anders als Scholz sprach
dröge über den Iran über Ungarn lobte
die EU für ihre Einigkeit beim Thema
Hilfen für die Ukraine nächster Redner
ist nur ein Tino krupala von der AFD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Landsleute
Herr Merz sie haben auf die Rede von
Herrn Bundeskanzler erwiderte Design
entsetzt weil Teile gefehlt haben was
ich in allen meinen Vorrednern auch in
ihrer Rede eben nicht gehört haben und
was mich entsetzt hat dass sie kaum ein
Wort über das eigene Land verloren haben
dass sie kaum ein Wort über die Sorgen
und Nöte der deutschen Bevölkerung
verloren haben das sagt eigentlich alles
aus
bereits die vergangenen Asien
Gipfeltreffen haben uns nämlich auch
eines gezeigt die Staaten wollen sich
nicht zwischen zwei
Verhandlungspartnern entscheiden darin
haben sie uns und Europa mittlerweile
einiges voraus sie werden die
zusammenarbeiten mich Interessen
geleitet ab anstelle sich durch
Sanktionen zu separieren und China meine
Damen und Herren gehört zu Asien
geographisch kulturell und
wirtschaftlich Differenzen gibt es auch
dort überall die kann man jedoch nur
gemeinsam beraten ohne die komplette
Öffentlichkeit in die eine oder die
andere Richtung zu instrumentalisieren
so kann jeder sein Gesicht waren und
Missverständnisse werden so auch
vermieden und genau diese sind in den
letzten Monaten schon oft genug als
Konfrontation wahrgenommen worden und
das Werte Kollegen genau das gilt es
auch zu vermeiden wir brauchen
Zusammenarbeit auf Augenhöhe niemand
möchte sich zuerst mit ideologischen
Denkansätzen seines Gegenüber
beschäftigen für eine Frie welche Welt
ist der respektvolle Umgang miteinander
der erste Schritt
und gerade
gerade die aktuelle Situation in
Deutschland zeigt dass wir als ein Land
ohne Rohstoffe und mit hoher Inflation
es uns überhaupt nicht erlauben können
ständig wirtschaftliche Sanktionen im
Namen der sogenannten wir haben es ja
heute wieder gehört feministischen
Außenpolitik zu erlassen dieses
Instrument schadet Deutschland ebenso
nachhaltig wie seinen Bürgern und genau
das muss ein Ende haben
und schon längst reden wir nicht mehr
nur über Russland mittels
Berichterstattung zur innenpolitischen
Auseinandersetzungen sendet die
Bundesregierung Signale an unliebsam
gewordene Länder aus wir haben es heute
auch gehört diese sorgen dort zumindest
für Erstaunen bis hin zu Unverständnis
denn über Jahrzehnte und das muss man ja
auch mal sagen hat man vernünftig
kommuniziert diplomatische Standards
gewahrt und wirtschaftlichen Austausch
gepflegt das waren die Leitlinien
deutscher Außenpolitik der letzten
Jahrzehnte aber spätestens seit dieser
Ampel Regierung stehen ideologische
Lehrstunden gegenüber anderen Nationen
und Kulturen mittlerweile auf der
Tagesordnung man unterscheidet nur noch
zwischen gut und schlecht zwischen
Schwarz und Weiß und da frage ich sie
können sie sich meine Damen und Herren
eigentlich noch vorstellen dass diese
Stimmung mittlerweile als feindselig
aufgenommen wird und die Frage sie wem
nutzt das
meinen sie das hilft den Menschen vor
Ort in den Ländern und ja die geführten
Auseinandersetzungen sind in Teilen auch
gewalttätig was wir als Alternative für
Deutschland auch nicht verteidigen ist
man aber ein besserer und
vertrauensvoller Partner wenn man von
außen einen vielleicht gewaltsamen
Regimewechsel aktiv Hawaii führen möchte
natürlich nicht die stellen sich und
damit Deutschland dauerhaft vollkommen
ins Abseits das trägt weder zufrieden in
der Region oder der Welt bei noch nutzt
ist den deutschen Bürgern mit ihrer
Politik teilen sie die Welt in zwei
Hälften Schotten Deutschland einseitig
ab und treiben so auch die Idee
Industrialisierung weiter voran
sie setzen mittlerweile den längst
eingeschlagenen Kurs der Merkel
Regierung fort dass der
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland schon
seit Jahren immer weniger attraktiv ist
zeigt die steigende Zahl der Firmen die
bereits abgewandert sind oder die es
planen und diese Zahlen die sind
alarmierend und die müssen auch im
Wirtschaftsministerium mittlerweile
angekommen sein sie konnte man in der
FAZ am 30 November diesen Jahres
nachlesen das bei einer Umfrage des
Statistischen Bundesamtes unter 600
mittelständischen Unternehmen
mittlerweile 20 Prozent bereits konkrete
Pläne haben Deutschland zu verlassen und
das ist nicht der Anfang von 2018 bis
2020 gingen bereits 1,6% der deutschen
Firmen diesen Weg also lange vor den
geeignissen des Jahres
2020 und sehr bedenklich sind zudem die
Geschäftsbereiche die vorrangig
ausgelagert wurden darunter die
Warenproduktion und deren Vertrieb aber
auch die Forschung und Entwicklung also
das letzte Know-how der letzte Rohstoff
Forschung und Entwicklung wandert
mittlerweile
und da verstehen sie da wirklich die
Signale ich weiß es nicht zuerst wurden
Produktionsprozesse aus Deutschland
ausgelagert und die Politik sagte wir
werden eine
Dienstleistungsgesellschaft das war hier
die Ansage aber das gehört mittlerweile
auch der Vergangenheit an auch
Dienstleistungen werden mehr und mehr
ausgelagert und da frage ich Sie warum
sollte sich überhaupt noch ein
Unternehmen in Deutschland ansiedeln
diese Frage können sie überhaupt nicht
mehr beantworten denn die Ursachen sind
nicht klar und die benennen sie kaum
noch hohe Sozialabgaben Steuerlast die
zu hoch ist Bürokratie und natürlich
nicht die zuletzt hohen Energiepreise
tragen genau dazu bei dass dieser
Wirtschaftssektor auch bald nicht mehr
existiert und das Deutschland auch keine
Wirtschaftsnation in dem Umfang mehr
sein wird
Beispiele sehen wir hier gerade auch in
Berlin tagtäglich Handwerksbetriebe wie
Bäckereien schließen und die Gastronomie
kann keine Angebote mehr machen weil die
Arbeitskräfte fehlen und das in einer
Bundeshauptstadt gehen Sie mal in ihren
Wahlkreis insofern sie überhaupt einen
haben und schauen sich die Lage mal vor
Ort an können sie ihren Wählern
eigentlich diesen Niedergang überhaupt
noch vermitteln und wenn ich die
Abwanderung mal betrachte die ja auch in
keinen Kontext mehr gesetzt wird seit
2014 verlassen jährlich fast 250.000
Deutsche dieses Land das sind bis zum
Jahr 2020 zwei Millionen Deutsche
Leistungsträger die dieses Land
verlassen und sie reden immer wieder von
Zuwanderung die Gründe dafür die sollten
Sie mal ermitteln denn das ist ein
Skandal
und sie dürfen mir glauben dass die
Bürger sehen und erleben Tag für Tag die
Folgen ihrer destruktiven Politik denn
diese führt unser Land auch in die
energiepolitische Sackgasse mit ihrer
Entscheidung die grundlastfähigen
Energieträger wie Kohle Gas aber auch
Kernkraft aus Deutschland zu verbannen
enthalten sie Bürgern und Unternehmen
die kontinuierliche Energieversorgung
vor und nein die aktuelle der
dunkelflauten können sie eben nicht
beeinflussen wohl aber ein vernünftigen
Energiemix wie wir es von der AFD immer
wieder gefordert haben sie als
Bundesregierung werden mehr und mehr zum
Treiber der Inflation sie sind die
Hauptursache der Inflation in
Deutschland
und deshalb machen sie die
energiepolitische Kehrtwende machen sie
endlich Politik für Deutschland und für
die Bürger sie haben die Aufgabe auch in
schwierigen Zeiten realpolitische
Lösungsansätze zu erarbeiten stattdessen
hören sie auf ihre Ideologie immer
wieder mit neuen Bedrohungsszenarien
durchsetzen zu wollen und wir die
Opposition werden sie immer wieder in
die Pflicht nehmen politiksymbole des
deutschen Volkes zu machen wir die
Opposition dieses Hohen Hauses haben die
Aufgabe ihre
Regierungspolitik kritisch zu begleiten
das ist der Kern unserer demokratischen
parlamentarischen Ordnung und nicht
Ihnen auf der Regierungsbank mit warmen
Worten zu schmeicheln das machen sie
jeden Tag schon selbst genug vielen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
das war Tino krupala von der AFD mit
natürlich heftiger Kritik an der
Regierung wirtschaftliche Sanktionen
müssen ein Ende haben ein Land ohne
Rohstoffe und mit hoher Inflation wie
Deutschland könne sich das nicht leisten
Christian dürr Fraktionschef der FDP ist
nun der nächste Redner vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen als wir im Februar nach Beginn
des russischen Angriffskrieges auf die
Ukraine zu einer Sondersitzung des
Deutschen Bundestages hier
zusammengekommen sind haben wir uns
gegenseitig versprochen dass wir dazu
beitragen wollen dass die demokratische
Welt in dieser schwierigen Zeit zusammen
steht dass die Europäische Union
zusammen steht und dass die Demokratien
der Welt die Ukraine unterstützen wir
können jetzt nach zehn fürchterlichen
Monaten des Krieges und die Vorredner
ist auf den letzten aber die Vorredner
die anderen sind darauf eingegangen
welche fürchterliches leid die Menschen
in der Ukraine dieser Tage immer noch
erfahren wir können nach 10 Monaten
jetzt feststellen die Demokratien der
Welt zusammenstehen meine Damen und
Herren das ist ein ganz wichtiges Signal
die Demokratien der Welt stehen gegen
den russischen aggresso zusammen liebe
Kollegen Kollegen ein ganz wichtiges
Signal auch für die Menschen der Ukraine
und jetzt
tagt der EU-Rat der Bundeskanzler sie
sind heute auf dem Weg zum asiengipfel
ich komme darauf gleich noch einmal zu
sprechen aber insbesondere die
Europäische Union allein wegen der
geographischen Nähe spielt an dieser
Stelle eine ganz wichtige geopolitische
Rolle das was dort besprochen wird wie
beispielsweise der ölpreisdeckel um die
russischen Staatseinnahmen zu drosseln
ganz konkret oder die Ausweitung der
personenbezogenen Sanktionen finden ja
die breite Unterstützung die sie hier
mit auf den Weg nehmen können und
gleichzeitig ist es wichtig dass was wir
geleistet haben und fortsetzen werden
ich denke an die finanziellen Hilfen für
die Ukraine die der Bundesfinanzminister
im Rahmen der G7 und der Europäischen
Union oder die justizhilfen die der
Bundesjustizminister auch im Rahmen der
G7 und der Europäischen Union und die
sie als Bundeskanzler im EU-Rat heute
noch versprechen und nächsten Tagen
besprechen werden meine Damen und Herren
wir stehen obgleich sich dieses Volk
mitten im Krieg befindet in dauernden
wir alle dauerndem Austausch mit den
Menschen und den
Führungspersönlichkeiten in der Ukraine
die Demokratien der Welt Deutschland die
Europäische Union sendet jeden Tag das
klare Signal an die Menschen der Ukraine
wir stehen an eurer Seite und
unterstützen euch wo immer es geht das
ist ein ganz wichtiges Signal diese
Woche liebe Kollegen und Kollegen
und an der Stelle will ich
auch ganz kurz auf die Europäische Union
selbst zu sprechen kommen die Einführung
des rechtsstaatsmechanismus war ein ganz
großer Schritt nach vorne denn ja wir
müssen offen sagen auch als Europäer wir
müssen offen sagen dass hier und da auch
die Rechtsstaatlichkeit innerhalb der EU
in Frage gestellt wird und ich will es
in aller Kleid unterstreichen Herr Orban
die Finanzhilfen für die Ukraine sind
keine Pokerchips in diesem Spiel meine
Damen und Herren wir wollen auch
Rechtsstaatlichkeit innerhalb der EU
durchsetzen starke Demokraten starke
rechter innerhalb der Europäischen Union
und dann müssen wir darüber hinausgehen
Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz hat es
angesprochen nämlich wie wir uns in der
Welt aufstellen auch als viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft meine Damen und Herren
der Inflation redakt beispielsweise der
US-Regierung der macht uns natürlich
große Sorgen keine Frage Herr Merz sie
haben hier ganz viele Fragen gestellt
Fragen die der deutsche
Vortrag in der letzten Sitzungswoche
längst beantwortet hat über die Fragen
Freihandel wir wollen vorangehen mit
Südamerika merkursor Chile Mexiko an
einen Neustart des vereinsabkommen mit
den Vereinigten Staaten alles Punkte
Herr Merz ich weiß da ist immer noch
viel aufzuarbeiten auch in ihrer
politischen Geschichte offensichtlich
gegenüber der eigenen Parteien der
eigenen Regierungsverantwortung alles
Punkt einer unionsgeführten
Bundesregierung nicht möglich waren wir
sind eine freihandelsnation innerhalb
Europas in den Freihandel waren wir
vorantreiben liebe Kollegen Kollegen
und an der Stelle will ich auch das
Ansprechen der Bundeskanzler sprach es
in Bezug auf den kommenden Samstag das
was wir in Deutschland machen konnten
als konkrete krisenantwort auf diesen
Angriffskrieg gerade im Bereich der
Energiepolitik wer hätte uns denn
ernsthaft zugetraut angesichts der
Tatsache dass Deutschland als
Langsamkeit als ein Land was hundertmal
nachgedacht hat was über ein Jahrzehnt
braucht um ein Flughafen in seiner
Hauptstadt zu bauen wer hätte uns denn
zugetraut dass wir innerhalb weniger
Monate ein lng-terminal in Deutschland
planen genehmigen bauen und am Samstag
in Betrieb nehmen werden meine Damen und
Herren das ist die Beschleunigung die
deutschland braucht das macht diese
Koalition liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und gleichzeitig schreiten wir bei den
modernisierungsprojekten weiter voran
ich denke an die digitalstrategie bei
planungsbeschleunigung sprach ich gerade
ich denke auch an die sozialstaatsreform
die wir machen mit dem Bürgergeld das
zum ersten Januar in Kraft treten wird
ich denke an Dinge wie die Absicherung
der gesetzlichen Rentenversicherung über
die aktienrente eine bafög-reform über
die handelsagenda Sprache ich gerade und
meine Damen und Herren zu den
Zukunftsprojekten dieser Koalition
gehört auch Deutschland endlich zu einem
modernen Einwanderungsland zu machen
meine liebe Kollegen Kollegen wir sind
weltoffen gleichzeitig machen wir das im
besten Interesse unseres Landes und
unserer Volkswirtschaft liebe Kollegen
diese Fortschritt diesen Fortschritt den
tragen wir nach Europa wir wollen
gemeinsam mit unserer europäischen
Partnern gerade in diesen harten
geopolitischen Zeiten zusammenarbeiten
und zu guter Letzt Herr Merz war ja viel
Kritik jedenfalls zu zwei Dritteln ihrer
Rede gegenüber dem Bundeskanzler und der
Bundesregierung dabei war wenn ich mir
die Zeitungsüberschriften der letzten
Monate anschaue im April Bundeswehr
Doppelpunkt März droht mit Blockade des
milliardenpakets Oktober Streit und
Bürgergeld CDU Druck mit Blockade
November März droht mit Blockade der
Preis Bremsen das ist zurzeit keine
konstruktive Oppositionspolitik und
ehrlicherweise ist es nicht mal ist es
nicht mal eine Politik der alternativen
zu der Politik dieser Bundesregierung
meine Damen und die Sprachbilder die sie
es gerade getan haben in ihrer Rede Herr
Merz die Sprachbilder von Bob der
Baumeister sind kein Beweis dafür dass
sie es an irgendeiner Stelle besser
können Liebe Kolle
ganz im Gegenteil ganz im Gegenteil
wir handeln noch diese Woche setzen wir
das Gesetz über die Strom- und
gaspreisgrenze in Kraft meine Damen und
Herren die zum ersten Januar gelten wird
niemand in Deutschland wird allein
gelassen aber natürlich wollen wir
gemeinsam Deutschland stärker machen in
der Zukunft ich würde mir wünschen und
das zum Schluss vielleicht als
Weihnachtsgruß in Richtung der Union ich
würde mir eine
Opposition wünschen die nicht nur
fordert preisdeckel bei Strom und Gas
ganz laut über Monate im Deutschen
Bundestag dagegen ist die nicht nur
fordern Freihandel und dann die
Bundesregierung fragt warum sie keinen
Freihandel macht obwohl wir es
beschlossen und erklärt haben schauen
Sie in was wir machen und gehen Sie
gemeinsam mit ein gutes neues Jahr 2023
mit und sich danke Ihnen
für fDP-Fraktionschef Dörr ist es eine
Lehre der letzten zehn Monate dass die
Demokratien der Welt zusammenstehen
gegen den russischen Aggressor und dass
sie alle ganz klar an der Seite der
Ukraine stehen starke Demokraten
Rechtsstaatlichkeit sei aber auch in der
EU wichtig eine klare Ansage an Ungarns
Regierungschef Orban es folgt Dietmar
Bartsch Fraktionschef der Linken nach
dem furchtbaren völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriff Russland auf die Ukraine hat
Europa hat die EU etwas erlebt was in
den letzten Jahren jedoch sehr selten
wieder fahren ist es gab Hoffnung es gab
Sehnsüchte die sich mit der EU verbunden
haben ja es war ein Einschnitt ja es war
eine Zeitenwende unbestritten aber Fakt
ist auch vor dem jetzigen erneuten
Treffen des Europäischen Rats sind diese
Hoffnungen vielfach verpufft und meine
Damen und Herren
immer feststellen dass die Fraktion der
Sozialdemokraten im Europäischen
Parlament aktuell in einem
Korruptionssumpf versinkt ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass das zumindest mal erwähnt
wird einer der größten Skandale den wir
in der letzten Zeit hatten meine Damen
und Herren das war unfassbar und kein
Wort dazu
und meine Damen und Herren auch die
krisenlösungsfähigkeit der Europäischen
Union die entpuppt sich immer mehr als
eine Luftnummer ja ich weiß es ist viel
getan worden und ich will auch deutlich
sagen wir als LINKE unterstützen alle
humanitäre Hilfe für die Ukraine und ja
ich sage deutlich danke an die
Hilfsbereitschaft vieler Menschen in
unserem Land die geflüchtete aufnehmen
ohne wenn und aber stimmt eben auch
254 Mal taucht das Wort Europa in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag auf aber für die
Menschen in Deutschland gilt leider und
täglich grüßt das Murmeltier die
Tagesordnung ist wie immer aber
europäische Lösungen für die Inflation
und für die Energiekrise da ist
weitgehend Fehlanzeige meine Damen und
Herren und das hat
zu tun mit der Bundesregierung das
Beispiel gaseinkäufe erst wollten sie
nicht nur doch dann die übergewinnsteuer
wollten sie nicht und werden anderen
Europa das lange gemacht haben haben sie
sehr lange mit einem anderen Namen und
eine Nummer kleiner das getan und was
ist eigentlich mit der europäischen
gaspreisbremse auch da keine Antwort ich
meine das us-investitionsprogramm sie
haben Fragen gestellt sie haben nach
Antworten gesucht ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass außer intensiven
Gesprächen hier klar gesagt wird was
wird denn da getan das ist mir alles
viel zu wenig ich sehe nur ein Maximum
an Selbstgerechtigkeit viele verprellte
Partner in der Union und vor allen
Dingen unzufriedene Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in Deutschland meine Damen und
Herren Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben eine
ihre Energiepolitik gelobt und den
schnellen Ausbau der Terminals und so
weiter aber zur Wahrheit gehört doch
auch seit Wochen herrschen Temperaturen
um den Gefrierpunkt und Millionen
Haushalte und Betriebe haben in den
letzten Wochen astronomische
Preiserhöhung für Strom und Gas im
Briefkasten vorgefunden keine dieser
Preiserhöhungen wurde vom
Wirtschaftsminister kontrolliert nur
erklärt Herr habitz zwar Preiserhöhung
werden null und nichtig außer sie können
durch die Beschaffungskosten begründet
werden aber wann beginnen denn nun
endlich die Kontrollen meine Damen und
Herren in zwei Wochen ändern sich die
Tarife müssen die Leute zahlen oder
nicht das ist unklar die Menschen haben
Existenzängste und sie kommen viel zu
spät meine Damen und Herren und ich bin
noch auf einen Punkt aufmerksam machen
die Erneuerbaren haben sie hier gelobt
ja das ist ja völlig richtig sie verbal
zu loben aber ihre Energiepolitik die
ist teuer und die ist klimaschädlich und
vor allen Dingen gibt es dort eine
erhebliche Doppelmoral meine Damen und
Herren die Wind Energie der Ausbau geht
seit 2017 stetig zurück und in diesem
Jahr stagniert das auf dem Niveau des
Vorjahres der großen Koalition das ist
die Wahrheit fast die Hälfte des
produzierten Stroms in Deutschland
stammt Phasen Weise aus der Kohle meine
Damen und Herren Deutschland ist unter
der Ampel die klimadrexschleuder Europas
das ist die Wahrheit meine Damen das ist
schlicht war die gute Nachricht ist der
die gute Nachricht ist das ein Jahr
schon vorbei ist aber ich kann nur eins
raten korrigieren Sie Ihre selbst
Zufriedenheit auch bezüglich Europas die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben besseres
verdient als dieses wir lassen niemanden
allein und lauwarme ankündigungs Brüssel
endlich weniger selbst
zusammenzufriedenheit und mehr
Engagement meine Damen und Herren
herzlichen Dank
der linke Fraktionschef Bartsch sieht
ein Maximum an Selbstgerechtigkeit und
viele unzufriedene Bürger erfordert von
der Regierung dass sie mehr und
schneller alle Erhöhung der
Energiepreise kontrollieren nächster
Redner Achim Post von der SPD
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren wenn man auf das Jahr
2022 zurückblickt muss man glaube ich
sagen es war und ist ein Jahr wie kaum
ein anderes
es ist ein Jahr das durch Putins
aggressiven Angriffskrieg Krieg wieder
auf diesen Kontinent gebracht hat es ist
ein Jahr das vermeintliche Gewissheiten
beschädigt oder sogar zerstört hat aber
es ist auch ein Jahr das
uns in Deutschland und Europa angespornt
hat
entschlossener und geschlossener zu
handeln und es ist ein Jahr
das
nachdrücklich und eindrücklich zeigt
eine
souveräne
soziale starke Europäische Union ist
unverzichtbar liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und
wenn ich zur Regierungsbank gucke und
zum Bundeskanzler kann ich für meine
Fraktion für die SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
gerade nach diesem Jahr und in diesem
Jahr erklären wir bedanken uns für die
Entschlossenheit und Besonnenheit der
gesamten Bundesregierung des
Bundeskanzlers Olaf Scholl
und diese Bundesregierung handelt in
Deutschland mit dem Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr mit drei entlastungspaketen
mit dem 200 Milliarden Paket dass wir in
dieser Woche beschließen werden zur
Deckelung von Energiepreisen zur Deckung
von explodierenden Energiepreisen und
diese Bundesregierung handelt in Europa
außenpolitisch gegenüber Russland
mittlerweile mit neuen
sanktions-pakete die so noch nie gegeben
hat in der Geschichte der Europäischen
Union sie handelt gegenüber dem Iran mit
einer Klarheit und Entschlossenheit die
sie von anderen Lena Werbung vorgetragen
wird und auch vom Bundeskanzler wie ich
sie noch nie erlebt habe in den letzten
20 oder 30 Jahren und das mal ganz klar
zu sagen
und sie handelt
im Blick auf die nächsten notwendigen
erweiterungsschritte fast 20 Jahre nach
dem Gipfel den Kopenhagen wo die bislang
größte Erweiterung beschlossen wurde mit
klaren Kriterien wann man beitreten darf
und wann nicht haben wir uns jetzt auch
den Weg gemacht nachdem jahrelang nichts
passiert ist unter der Führung dieses
Bundeskanzlers die nächsten Schritte zur
Erweiterung der Europäischen Union um
den westlichen Balkan zu machen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und diese Bundesregierung handelt auch
sicherheitspolitisch und
verteidigungspolitisch in einer Art und
Weise wie wir uns das wahrscheinlich
alle vor zehn Monaten noch nicht
vorstellen konnten mit dem
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr und auch mit
deutsch-französischen Projekten die
jahrelang in der großen Koalition
verhakt waren und wurden nichts
weiterging als sie die
Verteidigungsminister gestellt haben
nämlich mit dem Waffensystem dem neuen
Bomber FKS ein deutsch-französisches
Großprojekt für die nächsten Jahre und
Jahrzehnte liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und wir handeln das gehört nämlich auch
dazu auch
entwicklungspolitisch auch wenn man auf
humanitäre Hilfe guckt das was
Deutschland in den letzten zehn Monaten
für die Ukraine geleistet hat ist
wirklich vorbildlich und es ist ganz
billig das eine oder andere rauszusuchen
was einem gerade nicht passt lieber
Kollege Merz und wenn ich schon mal bei
ihnen bin
das einzige was mich irritiert bei ihren
Reden ist immer der Anfangsteil der
Anfangsteil ist immer staatsmännisch
kooperativ es stellt sich am Schluss
ihrer Rede immer raus das ist nur
gespielt es reicht nur zum
reklam-staatsmann Herr Merz
und das was Sie angesprochen haben Herr
Bartsch
natürlich natürlich muss man natürlich
muss man auch bei einer solchen
Regierungserklärung an einem solchen Tag
vor zwei wichtigen Gipfeln darüber reden
was nicht klappt in der Europäischen
Union oder wo es Missstände gibt und ich
fange mal an ja es gibt keinen Skandal
der Sozialdemokraten in der im
Europäischen Parlament es gibt einen
Skandal von einzelnen Sozialdemokraten
im Europäischen Parlament das das ist
was das ist richtig und das sprechen wir
ganz das sprechen wir ganz offen an ich
hätte mich gefreut wenn Sie das bei den
meisten Skandalen Sachen genauso gemacht
hätten das was ich da was ich da zeigt
ist zweierlei was ich da zeichnet zwei
Jahre alt ein Abgrund an habt ihr und
ein Abgrund an Korruption aber es zeigt
sich auch innerhalb von fünf Tagen
innerhalb von fünf Tagen Ausschluss aus
der Partei Ausschuss aus der Fraktion
und ein Beschluss des Europäischen
Parlamentes Absetzung als
Vizepräsidentin das ist schnelles
Handeln in fünf Tagen ist sie bei uns
mehr passiert als bei anderen in fünf
Jahren und es gibt noch was worüber man
reden muss
der Kollege dürr hat das zurecht
angesprochen natürlich ist die
Europäische Union mit 27 Staaten nicht
so dass alle so sind wie wir oder alle
so sind wie Frankreich oder alle so sind
wieder Niederlande nein das liegt in der
Natur der Sache wenn ich nach und nach
versuche die Europäische Union zu
erweitern es liegt nicht in der Natur
der Sache das einige Länder meinen sie
müssen sich nicht an Rechtsstaatlichkeit
Freiheit Demokratie Pressefreiheit
halten wie zum Beispiel Ungarn und
deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ist es richtig dass ein Meilenstein
gesetzt wurde mit dem Vorgehen der
Europäischen Union gegenüber Ungarn und
Orban Geld scheint doch wichtige Waffe
zu sein um solchen Leuten als jeder zu
kommen und er ist ebenfalls kein
Gewinner der letzten Woche er ist der
große Verlierer in Europa der große
Verlierer in Europa heißt Viktor Orban
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und zusammengefasst wir haben für 2023
ausgehend von dem morgigen Gipfel viel
vor in Europa wir werden in der
Wirtschafts- und Industriepolitik mit
diesem Wirtschaftsminister die
industriepolitische Agenda in Europa neu
schreiben wir werden bei den Beihilfen
deutlich mehr machen als bisher und wir
werden auf der Höhe der Zeit sein wenn
es darum geht uns neu aufzustellen was
die Wirtschaft und Industriepolitik in
Europa angeht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und der letzte Punkt und der
letzte Punkt ich bin sicher
dass das was der Bundeskanzler in Prag
erklärt hat dass der Fahrplan für
realistischen Fortschritt in der
Europäischen Union Schritt für Schritt
umgesetzt wird der erste Schritt dafür
wird auf diesem Gipfel passieren die
nächsten werden folgenden schönen Dank
Achim Post ist übrigens einer der
wenigen Redner der ganz ohne Manuskript
spricht er betonte wie wichtig die
Einigkeit der EU sei in diesen Zeiten
und lobte natürlich als SPD-Mitglied die
Regierung es folgt Alexander Dobrindt
Chef der CSU Landesgruppe im Bundestag
sehr geehrte Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
Bundeskanzler sie haben den
Vernichtungskrieg Putins gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung in der Ukraine
angesprochen sie haben noch mal deutlich
bekräftigt dass sie an der Seite der
Ukraine stehen wir unterstützen Sie bei
diesem Anliegen ausdrücklich immer und
immer wieder aber was sie heute erneut
nicht gesagt haben und das muss das
Leitmotiv all unsere Handlungen sein die
Ukraine muss diesen Krieg gewinnen was
ist so schwer daran
sie haben darüber gesprochen dass sie
Europa zusammenhalten wollen in ihrer
ersten Regierungserklärung der
Bundeskanzler haben sie gesagt dass sie
in Europa Brücken bauen wollen die
Bilanz allerdings in ihrem ersten Jahr
ihre Regierung ist doch eher dass sie
Deutschland in Europa zunehmend isoliert
haben es ist ihre
Verteidigungsministerin die Polen vor
den Kopf gestoßen hat weil sie
petritvereinbarungen nicht geheim halten
konnte es ist ihr Wirtschaftsminister
der Schweden vor den Kopf gestoßen hat
weil er aus ideologischen Gründen die
kernenergieversorgung Schwedens
gefährdet sie selber liegen mit dem
französischen Präsidenten im Streit Herr
Bundeskanzler der deutsch-französische
Motor in Europa er stottert sie bauen
keine Brücken sie reisen Sie ein das ist
die Wahrheit in Europa
sie haben hier intensiv heute über ihre
Neuausrichtung der Verteidigungspolitik
gesprochen sie haben in ihrer
Zeitenwende rede ja auch von einer
aufrüstungsoffensive gesprochen und
diese versprochen aber wie schaut denn
die Bilanz am Ende dieses Jahres aus
zwei Prozent für die Verteidigung sie
halten sie nicht ein 10 Milliarden für
die munitionsbeschaffung sie halten sie
nicht ein hundert Milliarden
Sondervermögen ausgeben für Beschaffung
sie halten es nicht ein ihre
Verteidigungsministerin organisiert
anstatt der Zeitenwende die Zeiten
Verschwendung das hat mit Fortschritt
nichts zu tun
und Sie haben ja auch von der
Energiesicherheit gesprochen in ihrer
Rede hier im Deutschen Bundestag am 1
Juni haben sie gesagt Energie muss immer
verfügbar sein 24 Stunden am Tag 365
Tage im Jahr die Realität heute ist eine
andere erst hat die Wirtschaftsminister
das Stromproblem grundsätzlich geleugnet
dann haben die Grünen ein Strom
sonderproblem für Bayern erfunden jetzt
erklärt dass grüne
ministerpräsidentenland
Baden-Württemberg hören Sie einfach zu
dass grüne Ministerpräsidenten denken
dann Baden-Württemberg erklärt dass
Abschaltung der Stromversorgung nicht
mehr auszuschließen sind ja Herr Habig
sie schalten die Kernkraftwerke ab
anstatt den Verstand ein ich würde Ihnen
sagen das hat mit Blackout nichts zu tun
das ist ein green out den wir hier
erwarten können
und weil wir ja über ihre Bilanz hier
auch reden der Bundesfinanzminister der
hat in dem letzten Monat noch gesagt
dass sie als Koalition nicht
beabsichtigten Steuern zu erhöhen letzte
Woche haben sie hier im Deutschen
Bundestag eine massive Erhöhung der
Erbschaftssteuer beschlossen vielleicht
vielleicht haben vielleicht haben sie
das etwas spät bemerkt und weil sie Herr
dürfen der FDP hier wieder den Namen
Horst Seehofer Zwischenrufen will ich
Ihnen schon mal sagen wir haben uns ja
daran gewöhnt dass sie von ihrer
Mitverantwortung in den letzten 20
Jahren in der deutschen Politik nichts
mehr hören wollen aber dass sie jetzt
schon ihre Mitverantwortung bei den
Entscheidungen von letzter Woche nichts
mehr wissen wollen das ist in der Tat
eine ganz neue Version
auch wenn Ihnen das möglicherweise hier
spät aufgefallen ist sie haben in der
letzten Woche die Freibeträge nicht
erhöht jetzt kommen sie drauf gestern
ganz offensichtlich dass man Freibeträge
erhöhen muss und schieben die
Verantwortung den Ländern zu ich sage
Ihnen wenn Sie bereit sind die
Freibeträge zu erhöhen dann liegt der
Ball immer noch im Finanzministerium
dann machen Sie doch einen Gesetzentwurf
dass die Freibeträge erhöht werden und
die Erbschaftssteuer die steigt wir sind
sofort dabei dies mitzumachen
und jetzt zum Schluss nur den Hinweis
der Bundeskanzler sie haben den Menschen
Respekt versprochen in ihrer ersten Rede
als Bundeskanzler kommt dieses Wort 30
Mal vor in ihrer letzten Rede und auch
heute Herr Bundeskanzler ist davon keine
Rede mehr ich wünsche mir für ihre
zweites Jahr in ihrer Amtszeit dass sie
wieder mehr über Respekt reden und
übrigens auch danach handeln Respekt
gegenüber unseren europäischen Partnern
Respekt gegenüber der nächsten
Generation Respekt gegenüber der
Leistung der Menschen in unserem Land
und übrigens auch als Weihnachtsgruß
Herr dürr Respekt auch gegenüber der
Opposition ich kann mal sagen ich habe
selten eine so destruktive rede hier im
Deutschen Bundestag von einer
Regierungskoalition gehört die von Ihnen
erwartet danke schön
das war Alexander Dobrindt von der CSU
mit heftiger Kritik an der Regierung die
ampeltour zu wenig für das
deutsch-französische Verhältnis weiße
eher Brücken ein als sie aufzubauen
nächster Redner ist nun Jürgen Trittin
für die Grünen
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
lieber Herr dobre und ich glaube Sie
haben ja gleich mehrere Chancen verpasst
die erste Chance wäre gewesen
dass Sie sich hier für das unselige
scherpick entschuldigen was ukrainische
Flüchtlinge in ankunftszentrum in Tegel
zeigt Solidarität mit der Ukraine heißt
Solidarität mit dem Menschen und heißt
nicht Politik Zulassen von geflüchteten
aus der Ukraine zu machen
die zweite Gelegenheit die sie verpasst
haben
sie hätten sich hier endlich mal für den
Begriff der klimaeraf entschuldigen
können und wissen Sie warum ich das an
dieser Woche sage
weil wir gerade damit konfrontiert
worden sind was die wahre terroristische
Herausforderung in diesem Lande ist
nämlich der bewaffnete Arm der
Reichsbürger mit den Beziehungen der AFD
hin kein Wort von ihnen kein scherpick
gar nichts das ist ein Massen mit
doppelter Moral
und vielleicht vielleicht sollten Sie
wenn wir über Europa sprechen
sich der Ernsthaftigkeit einig der
delegitimation dieses jüngsten
korruptionskandals
an der Stelle hätte ich mir eigentlich
gewünscht dass die CSU sagt ja
wir überdenken unsere Position noch mal
denn angesichts der bargeldhaufen die da
gefunden worden sind weiterhin dagegen
zu sein dass es eine Obergrenze für
Bargeldzahlungen gibt das ist meines
Erachtens genau die falsche Konsequenz
aus diesem Skandal
und letzte Bemerkung
wenn sie mir schon den Gefallen tun
als CSU-Mitglied als CSU-Mitglied über
Energiepolitik zu sprechen
dann erlaube ich mir die freundliche
Frage
wer hat dann die Situation herbeigeführt
dass die deutschen Netzbetreiber
festgestellt haben dass wir zwei
Norddeutschland eine Überkapazität von
Strom haben wir nicht wissen wohin damit
wir zum Teil Windparks abschalten müssen
aber in Bayern eine mangelage droht ich
kann Ihnen das Beantworten wer dafür
verantwortlich ist das ist der
esoterische einzelgang der CSU gewesen
die gewollt hat dass Gott keine
windelergie produziert hat und die jede
Stromleitung aus dem Norden in den Süden
blockiert hat wenn jemand ein
energiepolitischer Geisterfahrer ist
dann ist es die CSU in Deutschland
letzte Bemerkung meine Damen und Herren
das ist ja gelegentlich die traurige
Wirklichkeit die mir vorgefunden haben
als die Regierung übernommen haben
und die Frage wie wir in Europa
die wir in Europa mit dieser Situation
umgehen darauf hat diese Bundesregierung
eine Antwort gefunden
wir sind diejenigen die zum Beispiel in
global Gateway es vorantreiben in
Namibia in Chile mit dem Ausbau im
großen Stil erneuerbare Energien
Wasserstoff zu erzeugen aber
wir gehen auch nicht nur hin und sagen
wir machen dieses neue wir sichern die
Energieversorgung für morgen das ist
übrigens wenn ich das sagen darf nicht
nur eine gute Nachricht für die
Energieunabhängigkeit Deutschlands das
ist auch und gerade ein
partnerschaftliches Verständnis im
Umgang mit Ländern wie Namibia an dieser
Stelle das ist ein riesige
Entwicklungschance für diese Länder
aber
wir nehmen als G7 Länder auf viel Geld
in die Hand um beispielsweise gemeinsam
mit Südafrika deren Abhängigkeit von
Kohle zu überwinden das ist unsere
Antwort auf die Herausforderung vor der
dieses gemeinsame Europa steht
angesichts einer drohenden Bipolarität
zwischen den USA und China und diese
Antwort die gibt diese Bundesregierung
dafür
das war Jürgen Trittin von den Grünen
der jede Kritik an der Regierung
zurückwies er bezeichnete die CSU als
energiepolitischen Geisterfahrer es
folgt nun Alexander Graf Lamsdorf von
der fdp-
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
was für ein Jahr neigt sich diesem Ende
zu ein Jahr wirklich großer dramatischer
Zäsuren der größte Landkrieg in Europa
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ist
ausgebrochen
gleichzeitig ist es auch eine Zäsur wie
fest der Westen zusammensteht wer hätte
es zu Beginn dieses Jahres zu Beginn der
Invasion gedacht dass die schrecklichen
Entwicklungen der Versuch von Russland
totaleroberung der Ukraine so umfassen
scheitern würde wie wir das jetzt
beobachten Putins außenpolitischer
Handlungsspielraum ist deutlich
geschrumpft aber auch im Inneren auch im
Inneren scheint die russische Regierung
ihre eigene Legitimität in Frage
gestellt zu sehen zum ersten Mal seit
zehn Jahren
fällt die Jahrespressekonferenz des
russischen Präsidenten aus meine Damen
und Herren das ist eine bemerkenswerte
Entwicklung ganz offensichtlich sieht
sich Präsident Putin auch im Inland
inzwischen dem Druck ausgesetzt seine
Bevölkerung nach der Mobilisierung diese
schrecklichen Krieg zu beenden wir
können nur hoffen dass dieser Druck sich
auch dahingehend dass der Krieg eines
Tages ändert
zurzeit
das muss man auch so deutlich sagen gibt
es keinen Anlass zu Entspannung in der
Ukraine verfolgt Russland zurzeit eine
Politik der verbrannten Erde und diese
Art der Kriegsführung wirkt auch für uns
in Zukunft Risiken und Gefahren für die
wir in Deutschland und Europa gewappnet
sein müssen was bedeutet das gewappnet
sein es bedeutet das was wir im
Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten haben
erstens das transatlantische Bündnis ist
zentraler Pfeiler und zweitens die NATO
bleibt unverzichtbare Grundlage unserer
Sicherheit und drittens so haben wir es
im Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten leisten einen
unentbehrlichen Beitrag zum Schutz
unseres Landes für Frieden und
internationale Sicherheit sie stehen in
Emmering mit der Luftwaffe in Ruckler
mit dem her die nato-abwehr in der
Slowakei wird gestärkt und in dieser
Woche wird auch in Polen die Luft Abwehr
verstärkt meine Damen und Herren wir
hier genau wie unsere Wählerinnen und
Wähler können Advent und Weihnachten
voraussichtlich zu Hause in der Heimat
bei unseren Lieben feiern für viele
Soldatinnen und Soldaten gilt das nicht
sie leisten ihren Dienstplan der Heimat
auch in Mali oder Estland Litauen oder
dem Libanon Südsudan oder des Slowakei
wir denken an Sie und wir danken ihnen
für ihren Einsatz und wünschen ihnen
friedliche und fröhliche Weihnachten
fern der Heimat herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner der fraktionslose
Abgeordnete aus und Fragen zum Abschluss
noch mal meine Kollegin Ines Trams vor
Ort im Bundestag die ja dort die Debatte
beobachtet hat Ines wie hast du die
heutige Debatte empfunden vor allem die
Rede des Kanzlers wir haben ihn ja schon
mal sehr kämpferisch erlebt wie gab er
sich heute
heute war er nicht so kämpferisch wie
wir ihn hier bereits einmal im Plenum
des Bundestages erlebt haben dennoch
nachvollziehbar erwartbar hat Kanzler
Scholz hier heute nach seinem ersten
regierungsjahr eine positive Bilanz
seiner Europa-Politik gezogen
insbesondere verwies er wiederholt
darauf dass sich Europa nicht habe
spalten lassen im Zuge der Aggression
durch den russischen Präsidenten Putin
eine positive Bilanz zog er auch das
nachvollziehbar und erwartbar auch von
der Politik seiner
ampelregierung insbesondere verwies er
da auf den zügigen Umbau der
Energiepolitik in Deutschland und die
entlastungspakete
Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz von der
CDU brach dann dieses Selbstlob er
verwies darauf dass bislang noch keine
schützen und Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine
geliefert worden sein und er lastete
explizit Scholz persönlich eine
Verantwortung dafür an auch sprach märz
in scharfen Tönen den Tiefpunkt die
nicht funktionierenden
deutsch-französischen Beziehungen an die
Ampel die anderen ampelparteien die
Liberalen und die Grünen die zeigten
sich heute hier in der Debatte einig
gemeinsam verteidigten sie ihre Politik
gemeinsam griffen sie insbesondere
Friedrich Merz von der Union an für eine
in ihren Augen nicht konstruktive
Wirtschaft Wirtschaft und nicht
konstruktive
Oppositionspolitik
ja recht herzlichen Dank Ines das war's
für heute hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
der Sendung Notruf Hafenkante ich
bedanke mich für Interesse und sage
Tschüss bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]
heute